when we get to a point in society
where
beliefs that make no sense literally
are being imposed on civil government to
make law then I have a problem and yes I
may on some level mock those beliefs
there when it comes to private religious
views if you want to privately believe
in Noah's ark or
the Zeus or Thor or that you know a
Jewish Carpenter was the son of God born
to a virgin died then came back to life
and walked on water or whatever if you
want to privately believe that and not
impose it in any way
on civil governance and the way that
this country runs
okay go ahead and do it right I mean I
don't think it's accurate but go ahead
and do it